how you doing sir
good thanks I want to start with
congratulations on the show thank you um
I think one of the things that I want to
address right off the bat is a lot of
people had this notion that the Apple
shows we're gonna be all PG
family-friendly and after seeing episode
3 I can assure people it is a hard are
at least some of the aspects of this
show can you sort of talk about that
yeah I mean this was you know I know
people were talking about that in terms
of Apple and the sort of the idea of who
they are as a company and people were
worried about it but we never had to
change anything with the show this was
you know the show was pretty clear
tonally on the page when we sold it and
there were already two scripts not three
but there were two scripts and they were
you know pretty specific tonally and
they kind of bought in and they shared
our vision for the for the show and sort
of led us do you are do our thing what
was it about this material because
you're you you you work constantly
you've made some great movies what was
it about this that said I want to go
over to Apple I want to make a series uh
well I think that it was the idea that
its itself I'm on a bunch of fronts I
think one is I'm been a fan of Steve
Nights for a long time I like some of
the movies that he's written I like some
of the things that he's written that
haven't been produced yet I thought that
it had a very unique voice to it and
then it also has just a lot of aspects
of things that I like in terms of
storytelling
I love world-building this was a lot of
world-building and really challenging
and fun world building especially
because it had the sort of guiding
principle of blindness behind it which
meant every decision we would make would
be based on that idea which to me is
great and kind of grounding and guiding
in terms of having a principle I love
the idea of the world without
civilization I mean I had done a film I
am Legend that took place three years
after the loss of civilization this was
now hundreds of years so to sort of
explore a different facet of that I like
the idea of going out into the
wilderness and doing something very
authentically and as realistically as
possible so really going out you know
far distances and trying to
things and experience time and make make
the environments very immersive there
was just so many aspects to the show
that I that I loved how much did you and
Steven discuss the sort of over like
what's going on on the rest of the
planet coming up with like a show Bible
or a series Bible that can be followed
and how much is it sort of like let's
design the first season then we can see
what happens well Steve had a general
pitch for because we went in when we
sold the show we went in with two
episodes and I had a visual presentation
of my take on it and he had a pitch for
the rest of season one and then he had a
broader Pitchford sort of following
season so he had a pretty good idea of
where the show is gonna go very early on
well I'm curious like have you guys
thought about what happened to like
Detroit or what happened to this place
or you know what I mean yeah I mean you
know I don't want to get into spoilers
but you know we you know there's a lot
of traveling in this show so we end up
in different places and so you'll see
you know possibly later the season and
in other seasons ideally some of you
know what has happened in different
places that we find familiar one of the
things I thought was so cool in the
first episode is the community in what
basically how you can felt that felt
very real yeah this would really be what
happened if everyone lost their sight
with the ropes and everything can you
sort of talk about the challenges of
building all of that from the ground up
yeah I mean I think it's it's a
challenge to build that idea from the
ground up but it's also the fun of this
kind of world building it's one of the
things that I love about filmmaking and
so what we did very early on was we
actually had a think tank so we had a
gentleman that was blind a couple that
was blind and a survivalist and an
evolutionary biologist and sort of
everybody was just kind of brainstorming
and spitballing ideas that could play
into the narrative and also the
world-building
and then we put together a team so for
actors they had a blindness coach with
Jost rachet who's who's here with us
today and we had a movement coach that
was sort of I'd say primarily in charge
of the sort of cultural aspects of the
show in term
like okay you're a mountain tribe what's
that going to be like you know what are
the games you play the songs you sing
and you know all of that to sort of
create a rich tapestry for all the
different groups and tribes you know in
this world and so some of that was sort
of outside of blindness and some of that
was incorporated with the with the
blindness aspect one of the things again
no spoilers but there are some pretty
vicious fight scenes yeah
in the show and what's really cool about
it is that these characters are blind
yes having these intricate fight scenes
what the hell does it like to put those
things together and design them because
you're you I mean there's nothing like
it like I've seen in this kind of scale
yeah I mean it's tricky again fun tricky
but tricky and so you know if you look
at the big there's a big battle scene in
episode 1 and that we started
brainstorming very very early on in the
prep process and so one of the first
things we did was we wanted to just kind
of come up with fight style ideas and
ideas for you know how the different
factions would fight so if you're the
mountain tribe and you're gonna be up on
a wall what are the kinds of things that
you can do if you're coming from below
and going up the hill what are the
things you could do
what's the armor like what are the
weapons like you know getting into sort
of Judo style fighting because it means
there's contact and the idea of once you
make contact you don't want to lose
contact right until you are victorious
in some way and so we started to spit
ball all these ideas and gathering up
you know sort of a toolset for it and
then I would talk to the stunt team
about the kind of emotional beats and a
narrative that I want to take place
within the scene and then we kind of
built it all out from there but it was
always everything was always kind of
driven from this idea of blindness did
you you did the first three episodes yes
the series is eight yes was there ever
in your mind and do I want to helm all
eight of these well I thought that I was
gonna do all of them when I signed on to
do the show and then when I saw the
first set of outlines of the whole
season I thought just the scope of the
show there was no way that I would be
able to do all eight it would be do to
show a disservice just because the show
was so big and
so in terms of the prep and honestly I
had prepped it was sort of on the scale
of a large movie and I was you know
served barely prepared for my three just
because there's a lot to it because a
big cast route in really distant
locations we had this sort of piece a
lot of things together there's big
action there's a lot of animals there's
just you know a lot of elements to deal
with and so there's just no way I could
have done the other the other five what
did you learn making the show you know
there's a lot of talk you might have a
second season it's been picked up I
don't know the exact specifics but what
did you learn making the show that you
think will be able to be applied to the
second season because the first season
is always like building the
infrastructure and figuring it out well
I think a lot in terms of behavior and
sort of rules just because we we did a
lot of work in prep so that by the time
we were in the first day of shooting
people were pretty well versed in the
language of being blunt in terms of
blocking what do you you know what to do
with your eyes you know how to sort of
guide somebody to your hand if you need
to guide somebody to your hand the you
know to using the hand sign language you
know there was just a lot of that work
that went in very early but you know
then you shoot for nine months and so
people are like living and immersed in
that language and they get better and
better and better at it and new things
are you know people come up with new
things every day and so I just think
having that knowledge going into a
second season it would be fantastic I
gotta go thank you so much for your time
thank you Congrats on the series thank
you I'll talk to you later